reafirmando su influencia en la región
rusia desplegó unos 2.000 individuos
para el mantenimiento de la paz en
nagorno karabaj un día después de
negociar un histórico acuerdo de paz
entre armenia y azerbayán un acuerdo que
cumplió una ambición rusa de larga data
de mantener una presencia militar en la
antigua república soviética de libras
fuertes de mantenimiento de la paz de la
federación rusa se desplegarán a lo
largo de la línea de contacto en nagorno
karabaj y el corredor que une a nagorno
karabakh y la república de armenia el
acuerdo fue ampliamente aclamado como
una victoria diplomática para rusia que
una vez más se ha impuesto como un actor
clave en la toma de decisiones en la
región parecía un complejo desafío para
el kremlin que trataba de mantener su
audiencia militar con armenia al tiempo
que se mantenía en términos amistosos
con azerbaiyán una nación que compra la
mayoría de sus armas a moscú pero al
final fue rusia no turquía ni europa la
que intervino para negociar el acuerdo y
envió tropas para garantizar la paz sin
embargo los críticos han dicho que el
acuerdo que favorece a azerbayán podía
una señal de debilidad de moscú que
quería evitar ser involucrado en el
conflicto después de que uno de sus
helicópteros fuera derribado el lunes
pero esto también podría ser parte de la
estrategia del kremlin ya que mira al
primer ministro armenio nicole para
chillán con desconfianza y anhela el
regreso de uno que sea leal a músculo el
trato que ha sido descrito como una
capitulación por armenia ha puesto a pan
chillán bajo presión para que renuncie
hecho al que moscú probablemente no se
oponga